[Music]
[Music]
hi everyone thanks for joining us for
this online event whether you're
watching on youtube or facebook
or watching at a later time
my name is nicola hunt and we're here
tonight live streaming from the
riverside church in kaiapoi which is
also one of our civil defence centres
when we need it and is also located
within the yellow evacuation zone which
brennan will explain a little bit later
joining us is justin and brennan
justin is a natural hazard science
advisor at environment canterbury
working in the natural hazard science
team
justin's main area of expertise is in
understanding coastal processes and
coastal hazards and applying that
knowledge to better manage the risk to
people and property from coastal hazards
including tsunami
brennan is the emergency management
advisor for the waimakariri district
council
he oversees civil defence in the
district and is one of the key people
responsible for making sure our
communities stay safe
so what we'll cover tonight
justin will be talking about tsunami 101
pegasus-based tsunami hazards and the
science behind the modelling and then
brennan will talk to us about
waimakariri's tsunami evacuation zones
tsunami warnings what to do and how to
prepare
if you've got any questions just pop
them in the chat or comments box on
youtube or facebook
and now i'm going to swap places with
justin and he's going to go over the
science behind tsunamis with you we'll
be back in a tick
[Music]
thanks nichola good evening everyone
so waimakariri district has had tsunami
evacuation zones since 2012
and they were based on some previous
tsunami modelling tsunami modeling is
basically
just mathematical representation of
tsunamis in real life so they're
simulations of
of a tsunami
now
as with many aspects of science and with
with modelling
these
these models can become out of date so
we went through an exercise of redoing
our tsunami modelling for
for my market area district
and the outputs of that modeling showed
us that the previous modelling may have
underestimated some of the worst case
scenarios
of tsunami inundation or tsunami
flooding that could affect the district
so those
so that new science we're able to input
into determining these new evacuation
zones that brennan's going to talk to
you a little bit more detail about
later
so what are tsunami well
this is kind of what hollywood would
have you believe
a tsunami looks like
in reality
the reality is actually probably quite
different there's a
very very wide range of different
tsunami that can occur ranging from very
small hardly detectable ones
through to the very very large ones but
i can probably assure you that that
something like this is not likely to
occur in the waimakariri district
just an example of some of those
very small
almost undetectable
tsunami that we do get from time to time
in the canterbury coast
the image on the left here is
some traces of tsunami gauges which are
scattered around the country
these are
really sensitive pieces of equipment
that measure
tsunami waves as they as they travel
up the coast
as we can see
this is an example from 20 2009
there was a rather large tsunami in
samoa
it was a magnitude 8.
it took about seven hours to reach
canterbury
and we can see just here here is our um
a gauge sony tsunami gauge at littleton
and this one is at sumnerhead so we see
the the earthquake went off
take about seven hours for the first
tsunami's
first tsunami
waves to reach
which they can reach the canterbury
gauges
and this although it was a very
devastating tsunami in
samoa itself the wave heights in
christchurch were probably no more than
about 10 centimeters
another example a little more recently
on the right here on the 5th of march
earlier this year
there are a series of earthquakes
occurred off east east cape and the
north island
and up towards the kermit x
north of east cape
and again here is our here is out here
is our trace of tsunami gauges
we can see
the first earthquake was a 7.3 um just
off east cape and that was a very
localized localised event you can see
that the tsunami trace for the east cape
gauge
the earthquake goes off and in a matter
of maybe half an hour later
we had uh tsunami waves of about one
meter
occurring at the east cape gauge
but you notice very very little else if
we look down to uh to christchurch um no
traces of tsunami at all from from that
event
a few hours later on that same day the
kurmadek um there was an earthquake up
the coomadex this was a much larger
event this was an 8.1
magnitude event
and again
obviously had quite a big effect
locally
here our rail island
and the kumudik
kermedic islands tsunami traces and they
were actually knocked out either by the
earthquake or by the by the tsunami
but again if we look at the rest of the
country
very little impacts um after that after
that earthquake
were felt
one of the biggest
tsunami to affect canterbury in recent
times
was after a tsunami in 2010
from chile now this was again a very
very large earthquake
a magnitude 8.8
it took about 14 hours to arrive from
chile to
to canterbury
and
when the waves got to got to us they
were probably in the order of
half a meter to a metre so relatively
large large waves obviously the waves of
that height are not
not large enough to
cause any any flooding but what we did
experience
as you can see in these in these images
is
they can set up very strong and unusual
currents
in our coastal environment
for example
on the left hand side we've got
the okanes bay estuary you can kind of
see the the swirling eddies that this
particular tsunami
in 2010 caused and similarly the one on
the right is at
caroline bay in in timaru
again you can see the the swirling
eddies that
that occurred
as the as the tsunami wave came into um
came into the bay
so these are probably some of the more
likely and more regular tsunami events
that we will experience here um events
that will only really
not inundate but could cause
dangerous conditions within our water
bodies themselves
then obviously on the other on the other
side of things we can get these very
large
devastating tsunami events
for example
the unfortunate events that happened in
japan in 2011.
this was a massive earthquake a
magnitude nine
um locally in japan it caused waves of
up to around 15 meters
in some areas
but after that after that tsunami
reverberated around the earth
we did feel that in canterbury as well
the waves in canterbury
were probably around half a meter
in height so it's called similar
kind of
funny tidal currents and variations
in sea levels to a very small magnitude
around our coastline
so what are tsunami
well
generally
a tsunami is
caused by
some disturbance of the entire water
column or the entire
column of sea water above
say a fault for example
obviously faults are not the only
underwater faults are not the only
causes of of tsunami tsunami can also be
caused by
large landslides falling into a into a
water body or ocean they can be caused
by volcanic eruptions doing a similar
sort of thing disturbing the water
column
but by by far by far the most common uh
mechanism for causing a tsunami is an
under an underwater fault line going off
and the important distinction between a
a tsunami wave and just your normal
ocean wave
is that fact that the
tsunami wave disturbs all of the column
of water
ocean waves are caused by the wind they
caused by the wind blowing across the
across the surface of the water
and only the very top few meters of
of of the ocean is disturbed by a um by
a wind wave um whereas with a tsunami
it's that entire water column
and that's a very important
consideration um when we look at the
differences between a tsunami wave and a
wind wave now tsunami waves are also
called
long period waves
a period is basically the the time
difference it takes for the crest of a
wave to reach a certain a certain point
tsunami waves uh can be up to you know
tens often hundreds of kilometers long
in terms of their wavelength
but what they do do in in deep water is
they don't have much height so probably
even the very largest tsunamis won't
have a height greater than about a meter
or a meter and a half going through the
through the water column but the thing
they do do is they just move incredibly
fast so tsunamis can move at about the
same
same speed as a jet plane so we're
talking 700 to 900 kilometers an hour
and the deeper the water the faster they
move so tsunamis move really fast in
deep
water
but as they progress across the across
the ocean
and they come into contact with
shallower parts of the ocean they slow
down
and when they approach shore
they slow down
even more
so what we tend to get is that the
initial crest of the wave
slows down
the crest and the
the crest of the wave in behind though
is still going at that same at that same
pace at that that same pace
um so the
the distance between the waves tend to
shorten but remember we've still got
that energy that whole energy of the
water column
under those
under those crests
and what happens all that energy gets
transf transformed into an upwards
upwards of movement so that's when we
get these
um
these the wave height builds up when it
reaches the shore
the wave slows down
but even though it slows down when it
reaches the shore and when it inundates
the inundates the land it can still be
moving at speeds of up to 40 kilometers
an hour so speeds that are much much
more than we would be able to run
and one way you can think about tsunami
waves when they reach the shore is not
necessarily one of these large hollywood
type massive breaking waves they're
going to be look a lot more like
a very fast
incoming tide
and another aspect of that is that we're
going to get
not only is it a large fast incoming
wave
that wave will also
recede
as well
so ovis whereas a wind wave for example
um from the ocean might only you might
get a wave breaking every you know 10 to
15 seconds
a tsunami wave will come in and break
and it will keep breaking and keep
breaking and keep moving
for for for several minutes maybe even
an hour so we've got all and it's all
that big that massive water
within that wave that causes
the damage and these in these very big
events
and that's what makes tsunami so
dangerous
how an how a tsunami will impact
us depends on a number of
um a number of variables the first is
kind of the earthquake location and size
so as we've said if
it really has to like the earthquake
really has to occur under the water the
fault actually has to
push up that column of water
and obviously the the size the amount of
energy released in an earthquake is is
very important too
and different faults will move in in
many many different ways
so
the same magnitude earthquake
depending on how the fault moved
after the earthquake what part of the
fault moved
will really depend on whether or not
a tsunami is actually
generated or whether it's a smaller
tsunami or a big tsunami as we've also
said the shape of the sea floor
and the shape of the coastline is very
important
obviously
tsunamis slow down in shallow water and
speed up in deeper water they also can
bend around
coastlines and bays they are
amplified for example
in narrow harbors
and also that the state of the tide is a
very important element too when we're
when we're looking at the impacts of of
tsunami so obviously if we get for an
example a
you know a three or four metre tsunami
affecting the coastline
of canterbury
our title range is around two meters so
if that four meter tsunami for for
example arrived at um at low tide
you might be looking only at effects of
um you know above the normal high tide
level of a meter or so whereas if that
four meter tsunami occurred at high tide
you would get the full brunt of that
four meters of extra water
occurring at high tide so the state of
the tide is a very is very much a
consideration
so all those elements make figuring out
if a tsunami will flood
flood land
quite quite quite tricky
so this is um
a map of obviously new zealand
but also a map of the
um the different colors represent the
different
different water depths
off the coast of new zealand and also as
you see new zealand is obviously very
tectonically active
which makes
which makes us quite vulnerable to these
to these local and um
and regional source tsunamis
new zealand obviously straddles
two continental plates as we can see
here on the
on the right hand side is the is the
pacific plate
and on the left is the
australian plate
um so the the pacific plate is diving
under
the australian plate um and where these
um where these plates
join and where one goes under the other
they're called subduction zones so
there's three main subduction zones that
we have in in new zealand there's the
kermadec subduction zone up up north of
new zealand stretching up to the kumeric
islands there's the hikarangi subduction
zone
off the east coast of the north island
um
and then the pewsiga subduction zone
off the south south island of the of the
country
um so this makes
and these subduction zones are quite um
vulnerable to quite large potentially
tsunami generating
earthquakes
pegasus bay is exposed to i guess we
call them three different tsunami
sources
uh the first one is local source tsunami
so local source
tsunamis are
tsunamis that we would expect
less than an hour's warning to arrive
to arrive at the coast so for us in
pegasus bay we're talking
any tsunami source
upwards towards
within pegasus bay itself but also up
towards kaikoura and even to the
southern part of the hikarani subduction
zone um probably if you know if an
earthquake that generated a tsunami went
off there we would expect an hour or
less warning for um for that tsunami to
affect us
the second type are regional source
tsunamis so we can see on our on our map
here this thick
gray line if you can see that okay this
thick gray line so that's kind of an
area where we expect
regionals regional tsunamis to to occur
and these are the tsunamis that we would
expect probably um would take between
one and three hours to arrive um on the
pixar space
bay shoreline
now these are the kind of the tsunamis
that you would probably
the earthquakes that generated them
you
you would probably
feel them
as a as a as a long earthquake
not necessarily strong because they'd
look a little bit further away but you
would expect them to be long rolling
motions of an earth of an earthquake
and the third the third
the third tsunami source that
we are um we're vulnerable to uh distant
source tsunamis so these are tsunamis
kind of outside this grey blobby line
thus those tsunamis that we could expect
um would take greater than three hours
um to reach us
so as an example
um
distance source tsunamis might be
might be sourced
from south america central america even
alaska and as we said before japan we do
get tsunamis
if they're generated this far away can
still can still reach us and still and
still affect us
in fact
some of the biggest tsunami that have
affected uh the canterbury coast have
been from these distant source tsunamis
and that's what our modelling tells us
as well um particularly
vulnerable to um to tsunamis generated
from from south america they've got an
under uninterrupted um travel distance
and run all the way from south america
bang into into pegasus and pegasus bay
so
central government tells us for our when
we're designing our evacuation zones
that we have to model the evacu
have to model evacuation zones based on
what we call a worst case
tsunami so we're obviously
evacuation zones are for life safety
so we want to plan for the worst but
hope for the best
and when we say worst case
and as i'm going through some of these
examples the worst case you can think of
as about us
we could expect an event of this size to
occur you know once in every 2 500 years
but probably a better way to think about
that
is in terms of a human lifespan so say
for example if a if the average human
lifespan is kind of 80 years
um
we would expect an event
of this size a one in 2 500 year event
perhaps to
to happen
have a percent chance of happening in
someone's lifetime
so
very unlikely
but certainly um certainly possible and
we really need to um we really need to
plan for those
unlikely but possible large
life-threatening events
we had gns science do the do the tsunami
modelling for us
and as i mentioned earlier
the previous
modelling that was done for for the
waimakariri district
back in 2012
used one single um scenario it was a
scenario of a large earthquake going off
um in south and south america
now with the um the latest modeling what
gns science have done is they've
actually modelled hundreds and hundreds
and hundreds of different types
of of um
of of tsunami
and
done what they call an ensemble
an ensemble model so basically pushed
all those
all those results together to find a
worst case scenario and these are what
these these models show us
so just by way of example what i've got
here is
one of these one of these kind of worst
case scenario
earthquakes
tsunami generating earthquakes
and this one here is a
nine magnitude earthquake on the
southern hikarangi subduction zone so
where our where our red blob is here
this is an earthquake happening um
towards the end of the haringey
subduction zone kind of offshore
from cook straight so the very southern
the southern end
so this is kind of bordering on our
local
slash regional source tsunami so the
travel time is likely to be
one hour
or even less than one hour for the first
waves to arrive
um
and we would expect wave heights of up
to nine meters above normal sea level um
to occur
but as i said this is the this is this
is the worst of the worst case
scenarios
it's very very hard to model or predict
what sized
earthquake will cause what size tsunami
waves
but this is what we believe to be the
most credible worst case scenario for
for an earthquake like this
and the picture on the on the right hand
side
basically shows what we could expect uh
the inundation or the flooding
to be like from a tsunami of this of the
size from generated from this particular
location
and if we look a little bit closer
um
the most vulnerable areas of of the
district
what the modeling what the modelling
showed us is that
the coastal dunes
of the waimakariri district we've got
some nice big lovely well-vegetated
healthy
sand dunes
so they are likely to
absorb and stop
much of the direct inundation from
from a tsunami like this but where we'd
expect the flooding to come is in our
low-lying areas around our river mouths
so up near our ashley river mouth and
waimakariri river mouth
the inundation is expected to come up
the river mouths and flood around the
back of the the back of the dunes and
around the back of the back of the beach
rather than directly over topping the
dunes
themselves
the second the second example we've got
here or the second
tsunami scenario
is a magnitude 3 earthquake
up at the uh
the southern um kumudik subduction zone
so around off our east off our east
coast
area
travel times for this one we're looking
at around
two metres for the first waves to arrive
and again similarly to our to our
previous example we'd expect wave
heights of up to nine meters above
normal sea level
but again this is the worst case and
they could be they could be much less
could be much less
and just a third example um of our of a
scenario is one of our distant source
tsunami
earthquake off the coast of of south
america a really really large earthquake
a magnitude 9.45 earthquake now to put
that into perspective
the biggest ever recorded tsunami uh
sorry the biggest ever recorded
earthquake
since we've been able to able to measure
these things um was a 9.5 earthquake
so
this kind of this kind of this kind of
earthquake that we're talking about in
this scenario is getting up there pretty
much with the largest earthquake that's
ever been recorded
tsunami generated in this location
travel time to new zealand or to the
canary coast will be about 15 15 or 16
hours
but the wave heights could be up to 12
meters above the sea level so really
really quite quite large um large waves
could be expected from a from a from an
earthquake
from this location
and again
similar example in terms of our
inundation extent
coming in through
the mouths of the of the ashley and the
waimaki waimakori rivers but extending
quite a bit further
inland
but we also asked gns
to model
several different tsunamis generated by
that could cause maybe smaller
smaller sized
events
okay so
we've talked about these worst case
scenarios but as i said before
we're more than likely to get
waves tsunami waves
that are slightly smaller than this so
it's interesting to know what
what areas those smaller type events
could
could inundate
so this is just a just just an example
of okay so if we got a three metre
tsunami what areas would would be
affected
and for the waimakariri district
obviously um we're looking we're looking
pretty good
maybe it's just some some minor
inundation again around the river mouths
um at the the waimakariri and the
the ashley estuaries but certainly no
no an inundation
anywhere else
we did a similar sort of thing for a
five meter wave
so i'm not you know a significantly
higher wave than
than the three meters
and again
really interesting to see that very
little um very little impact behind the
behind the dunes for most of the most of
the coast and again limited to our um
to our river mouth environments
the probably one of the one of the good
news stories to come out of the
modelling is that
it's unlikely that any of the offshore
faults
off pegasus bay
themselves gns looked at 20 different
fault sources within pegasus bay
and when they modeled them none of those
none of those earthquakes
generated by these faults would be big
enough to cause a tsunami
any greater than than three meters
just give a little bit of a rundown on
how we know a tsunami is coming and the
warnings associated associated with them
we don't really know for sure whether a
tsunami is being generated
until it reaches one of our
coastal sea level gauges or one of our
dark boys now
um a dart boy it stands for
deep water assessment and reporting
of tsunami and these are very sensitive
devices
placed on the sea floor
connected to a boy which will which
sends the signal from them
to instrumentation on shore
so when there's so really when there's
an when there's a very large earthquake
the initial response is okay is this uh
in a location or a position
on the planet that could cause a tsunami
somewhere
that's the only indication to go by and
it's not until a tsunami reaches one of
these early detection
buoys or gauges that we really have an
indication that yes there is actually a
tsunami
that has occurred
and obviously not just around new
zealand but these dark boys are
scattered all around all around the
pacific
and they basically are early warning
detection that are
that are that an earthquake um has
caused um a tsunami but i think the
thing the thing to uh the thing to note
about tsunami warnings is that
there is just so much information being
fed
to the scientists
all the time
the initial earthquake magnitude is
often
takes a while to
to be refined so often the initial
magnitude that that that is recorded um
will be changed as the earthquake waves
generate around the around the earth um
and a very subtle difference in
earthquake magnitude could make quite a
big difference to the size of the of the
tsunami and all these things take time
so
so it can take
a while for the relevant authorities
to
to make a decision that there has been
an uh
there is a tsunami coming and how big it
is and what areas should be should be
evacuated
and this is just an example um of some
of the information that that that comes
to
our local civil defense authorities when
there has been a
tsunami tsunami warning
so our local authorities will get
get a threat map
with
what our what our
national experts think based on the
information that they've received
either from overseas or from locally
from our own tsunami gauges or our own
dart boys as to which areas might be
affected which areas won't be affected
into into what degree
and then this information is used by our
local some civil defense authorities
to generate
tsunami evacuation warnings which
brennan will talk to a little bit more
about about in a minute
um so i guess from me some of the
take-homes
is that
most tsunamis are small and won't flood
land
but they can still cause dangerous
currents
in the sea and river mouth areas
pegasus bay
though is still vulnerable to some of
these large tsunami
both from a
a regional source and a distance source
and although they're rare
they can
they
they do have the potential to cause
quite a bit of damage
brenda's going to talk about evacuation
zones so if you know you're in
evacuation zone
have a plan
and
the final message that again brennan
will reinforce
is
because of because of what i've told you
about the length of time that it can
take to actually pinpoint where and how
big a tsunami might might be could take
several hours and sometimes for these
local source and regional tsunamis you
don't have several several hours to wait
so a natural warning is probably the
best warning so if you feel a long or
strong earthquake
get gone from those red and orange zones
um don't wait for someone to tell you
what to do
um so now i'll hand over to to brennan
to to go through a little bit more about
what the tsunami evacuation zones
are and entail for for the ymcar
district
[Music]
[Music]
i'm going to talk now about our
evacuation zones and as justin said
earlier the evacuation zones are not
identical to the tsunami inundation
zones in some cases we've had to stretch
the evacuation zones out to meet the
nearest road and in other cases we've
had to shrink the evacuation zone to
meet the nearest road we want to use the
roads as boundaries because they are
things that people can identify with
particularly local residents know most
of the streets nearby to their homes so
there are easy reference points for them
if they ever have to evacuate
so our first evacuation zone is the red
zone and the color coding system that
we're using here is a national standard
across new zealand throughout the civil
defense sector so you will find the same
sorts of colors being used in
christchurch city and hiranui to our
north
so our red zone is the area most likely
to be affected by tsunami and for us in
its simplest terms it's pretty much the
beach sandy area
and at the river mouths so where the
people are fishing where people are
swimming where children are building
their sand castles in the summer time
the beach sandy area and the river
mouths particularly the ashley and the
waimakariri river mouths are the areas
you need to be worrying about as far as
our red zone is concerned so
if you feel a long or strong earthquake
one that lasts for a minute or longer or
nearly sweeps you off your feet you need
to get gone get away from the red zone
as quickly as possible don't wait for a
warning if you hear the sea making loud
unusual noises or you see the sea
behaviour the water behaving in a way
that's most unusual get gone get out of
there straight away
if you hear a civil defence warning
system
telling you to evacuate get out of the
red zone straight away
our next zone is the orange zone
so this is an area inland that is
potentially going to be inundated when
tsunami occurs
similarly to the red zone there's a good
chance you're going to feel the
earthquake that causes the evacuation of
the orange zone so once again if you
feel along the strong earthquake get
gone if you hear the sea making unusual
noises or you see the sea water behaving
in a really unusual way get gone or if
you hear a silver fence warning to
evacuate the orange zone get gone
straight away
our next zone is the yellow zone
so this is an area that is
possibly going to be inundated by
tsunami it is less likely than the
orange zone or the red zone that this
area will be inundated
it is most likely that you're not going
to feel the earthquake that causes this
so this is probably going to come from a
distant soul tsunami from perhaps south
america it could take as long as 12 to
17 hours approximately from the time of
the first earthquake before the first
tsunami wave arrives on our shores and
you will not feel the earthquake that
causes this
so your only warning really is going to
be official warnings from civil defence
so if you hear the warnings to evacuate
the yellow zone evacuate immediately
then we have the white zones or the
areas that are not part of our formal
official tsunami evacuation zones so if
you're outside the red the orange and
the yellow zones you are in a zone that
is themed safe you are not at risk of
earthquake when you're in these zones so
even if you
hear a
official warning to evacuate because of
tsunami you do not need to evacuate the
white zone if you live in this area you
might even want to open up your home as
a safe refuge place for people who are
evacuating from any of the other zones
so i explained before that i was going
to zoom into the maps and show you how
our evacuation zones have evolved what
you're looking at on the screen right
now is what used to be our tsunami
evacuation zones and you can see that
they are one two
three
four separate polygons
and because of the new science
assessment this has now changed and
these are no longer our tsunami
evacuation zones
what you're seeing here is our new
evacuation zones and it's pretty much
one
large polygon with the three different
colored zones in it
so this map is the council's publicly
available map
you can go into this map at any time
through the council's website and you
can go into an exact version of this
through environment canterbury's website
as well
and if you think you live inside or near
one of these evacuation zones you can go
into
the window there and just like google
earth you can insert your property
address and it will take you in
right to where your property is and i'm
just going to randomly pick a property
inside kaiapoi
and we can see now
that our map has taken us right to that
property address
and the color zoning there is orange and
if you were to touch
on your property
a little balloon will pop up and will
tell you where your address is and it
will tell you in words which of the
tsunami evacuation zones you are in
and through this mapping system you can
zoom in or out
you can change the the background so
that it looks like an aerial satellite
map just like you see on google earth or
you can change it into a topographical
map for those people who like to use
contour lines
i'm going to talk now about our tsunami
warnings
so there isn't just one type of warning
system we have a layered system and
there are generically two types of
warning there are natural warning signs
and there are official warning signs so
the natural warning signs
once again if you feel a long or strong
earthquake one that lasts about a minute
or longer or one that nearly sweeps you
off your feet
get gone get out of the tsunami
evacuation zones straight away unless
you're in the yellow zone and you can
afford to wait for the official warning
but you're not going to feel that
earthquake anyway
the second natural sign
is that the sea makes a really unusual
noise or you see the sea water behaving
in a weird way perhaps it looks like
most of the sea water has sucked back
out into the pacific ocean
and so you need to quickly get out of
that area straight away
and the third one is if you hear the
loud noise of the sea it sounds really
unusual perhaps like a jet engine or a
train that's a good sign to get out of
the area
looking at the official tsunami warning
signs that civil defence will issue
there's a series of six layers and we're
going to use all of these at the same
time
so the very first one is the emergency
mobile alert system this is a system
that is owned by central government it's
activated by the national emergency
management agency in wellington
and it will target any cell phone that
is capable of receiving an alert you
don't subscribe to these they will
automatically turn up on your phone if
your phone is capable of receiving them
listen to those warnings and adhere to
whatever they say
the next one is radio and television so
at the national level the national
emergency management agency will
broadcast messages over tv they have an
arrangement with new zealand tv to make
that happen rather instantly
and nationally regionally and locally
civil defence is using nearby radio
stations for the waimakariri district
and all of north canterbury we are using
radio compass fdm so 104.9 compass fm
and you will hear messages coming across
there and our council will broadcast
messages through that radio station live
for as long as we need to
the council website and the council
facebook page are probably our primary
source of
intelligence and reliable information
from the council so we will be posting
information on both of these platforms
instantly when we know that tsunami
threat is prevailing
so our next one are coastal warning
siren systems and currently in waikuku
beach wooden beach and pines kairaki
beach we have siren systems that are
connected to a computer console in
rangiora and we will broadcast messages
through those sirens our sirens have
some pre-recorded messages some that are
specifically about tsunami and we also
have the ability to broadcast live voice
messages through those siren systems so
listen for those you are likely to hear
a loud siren noise first
followed by a pre-recorded message
and then possibly followed by some live
voice recorded
and then our final layer is emergency
services people
our responders going door to door
knocking on those homes that are in the
beach areas or inside the evacuation
zones to tell you you must leave and
this is probably going to be our last
port of call but as i say all six of
these layers of warning will be
occurring at the same time
so there's an example of our coastal
warning siren system there is one
lamppost in each of waikuku beach
wardian beach and pines kairaki beach
the array of sirens on the top of those
are very similar but what they can do is
identical and we can control that from
rangi aura or remotely via cell phone or
two-way radio that council owns and
certain staff have access to that
how should you prepare
so we have a lot of information that we
push out to the public through our
libraries through the council service
centres sometimes we'll drop them into
reasonably public places like
medical clinics and there's lots of
booklets with lots of information about
how your family can prepare itself and
prepare its household emergency kit box
so if you already have a household
emergency plan with some evacuation
arrangements in it
follow that plan get yourself to the
family's assembly area and if that
happens to be outside of our tsunami
evacuation zones then you're in a good
state
if your plan doesn't do that just make
sure you get outside of the tsunami
evacuation zone
and within our district the waimakariri
pretty much if you get west of state
highway 1 you're going to be safe as you
can see from our tsunami evacuation
zones and i'll blow that up shortly on a
map
there are a couple of areas just west of
state highway 1 where the evacuation
zones extend but they are mainly
unoccupied pasture lands
so what to do when you evacuate
grab your household emergency kit your
grow bag if you have one of those and
get yourselves as quickly as possible
with medicines with your children your
babies with your pets
and out of the evacuation zone as
quickly as possible
secure your home as you normally would
when you leave home to go to work each
day
it's quite possible you will have to
remain outside the evacuation zone for
several hours perhaps even days
depending on how much damage has been
done
stay informed there are different ways
to get information out of the council
and we will be broadcasting information
to the public about which civil defence
centres you can evacuate to and we'll be
putting maps up on facebook and the
council's website to show exactly where
they are
where they are which ones we use can
change on the day depending on how the
science assessment tells us that the
water inundation is going to look
listen to the local radio particularly
compass fm if you're in the waimakari
district or if you're anywhere in north
canterbury
making your plan first of all know your
zone know which tsunami evacuation zone
you are in or which one is closest to
you and where to go to get out of it
quickly have an evacuation plan for your
household
and
if you don't have a template for that
the council provides those through our
booklets that are available in each of
the council service centres and
libraries
discuss your plan with your family
members particularly your children so
that everybody knows what the plan says
where to meet and how you will do that
ladies and gentlemen that concludes my
part of the presentation i'll be happy
to take any questions
so that concludes the presentation
tonight and now we will move on to
questions and answers
our first question from dan
will pegasus and kaiapoi be getting
tsunami sirens now that they're in
tsunami zones uh brennan i think that's
probably a good question for you
yeah so um this is a really good
question each of our beach communities
has something in common and that is
pretty much a single road in and out
so congestion is a potential risk in
most of the areas particularly the beach
communities
and pegasus itself has a very similar
feature about its community but it's
important to remember that pegasus is
sitting inside an orange zone for most
of the parts of pegasus that are
affected and there's a very small area
that's in the yellow zone
and both the orange and the yellow zones
we do have time for those evacuations so
the parts of pegasus that are orange
which is only a very small part are
going to have approximately one to three
hours notice
from the time the earthquake occurs
before the first wave would be expected
to arrive
so yes congestion getting out of that
one route
is an issue but you don't have to go far
and you don't have to leave pegasus
township because where the school hall
is is a designated evacuation centre and
it is in the clear so it's quite safe to
go to pegasus township hall
in terms of wood end it's like the other
beach communities so you do need to
think about giving yourself time to get
out of there and people also need to be
prepared that if they think the roads
are too congested
think about walking think about leaving
the car behind
that may have to occur in some places in
some instances
great thank you brennan
and a question from liam does the
modelling take into account the current
models and data on predicted sea level
rise and how much does this change
current inundation zones
justin
yeah thanks um thanks liam for that
question um
the modelling
assumes that the tsunami will occur at
at high tide
just to be
on the conservative side on the safe
side
and obviously as sea levels rise that
base level on which the modelling
applies
will increase as well
but really what we're interested in um
for evacuation
zoning is what's happening in the here
and now
and
sea levels probably in the next
10 years or so
where
we're thinking that they you know
potentially could rise between you know
10 and 20 centimeters
um in the next 10 years but that's also
kind of the time period we would be
looking at
reassessing
the evacuation zones and redoing the the
modeling
um
so
um in you know in a few years time when
we do re-evaluate the modeling um we'll
take into account the sea level rise
that's that's happened subsequently um
yes so the answer is that that the
modeling at the moment doesn't um but
any future modelling will
will take into into consideration those
um
those uh historic city will rise
great thanks justin
and a question from rick
how big was the kermadec island tsunami
when it took out the tsunami sensors
back to you again justin
unfortunately we don't know because i
believe it was the earthquake the
effects of the earthquake that knocked
out the tsunami sensors
i think some equipment fell over and
power power was power was lost to the
actual tsunami
tsunami gauge on rail island so
we're not really sure how large that
that tsunami was there unfortunately
okay
we have another question from liam has
the wdc and civil defence specified
where people should go
if specific areas are being asked to be
evacuated to avoid congestion
and are there preferred evacuation
routes to take
cure liam so the answer uh in the long
is yes
so something that we're still in the
process of doing is replacing all of the
current signage and tsunami information
boards that are on our coastline we've
only just very recently come up with the
new tsunami evacuation zones themselves
so it takes us a bit of time now
to produce new maps new signage replace
what's out there already
so in the current signage we did show
where the evacuation routes are where
the evacuation centres are and we plan
to do that with the new round of signage
that will be going up over the next year
or two
thanks brennan
well that looks like it wraps up our
questions and answers for this evening
so thanks again everybody for joining us
and for asking some really good
questions if you do think of anything
else we're here to answer them just
contact the council through our facebook
page or contact our customer services
team
thanks again and have a great evening
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you